this is for I checking in for big thing
calm
Michael Jackson's identity was something
that we will never fully understand
starting out as an incredibly gifted
young black boy raised in what by all
accounts was a very domineering
household he became incredibly
successful but also seemed to crack
under the strain and his incredible
physical transformations his skin
lightening the eye surgeries what he did
with his hair in addition to his fashion
sense sometimes drew him acclaim but
also drew a sense of confusion
especially from many people of color who
wondered if he really hated himself
enough to do these things to be unlike
himself I think that he was well ahead
of the curve in terms of extreme plastic
surgery and now we are more used as a
society to seeing extreme plastic
surgery but his transformation was very
visual and very literal at the same time
Michael Jackson was a hero to so many
people simply because he kept
reinventing himself the it's like that
video for black and white where they
show people morphing into each other you
know black or white excuse me and in a
way he was all of those things he did
morph constantly like you know CGI on a
fancy movie he was someone who could
transform himself in an instant what he
didn't seem to get a lot closer to was
happiness he had three children he had
two women who helped father or you know
who gave birth to those children that he
fathered although some people again very
much rumors say that he was not actually
the biological father of the children
but before I digress he was someone who
had at some point just about everything
enormous amounts of property
intellectual property from the beatles
catalog children the ability to go
internationally anywhere he wanted and
you know just vast amounts of things
that you think would make you happy but
Michael Jackson is in addition to being
an incredible talent also a cautionary
tale that
everything that you touch when it turns
to gold that means it's bit frozen and
you can't really use it
I'm not sure that that was the case I
think however there was a distinct
confusion about whether or not his
transgressive pneus as someone who was a
persona also was marred by the
allegations of him being a pederast it's
one thing to be alternative and to set
your own path and there's another thing
entirely to abusing children and I think
that some people some fans of his in the
end had a really difficult time making
up their mind whether oh that's just
Michael being Michael you know the way
he dresses the way he acts the way he
keeps his kids under scarves or whether
there were signs of a more troubling
psychological illness that could have
caused harm to him and two other people
including miners that was one of the
real fundamental issues that is not
going to be forgotten during this whole
period of mourning for Michael Jackson
because there have been some very
difficult moments although he was not
convicted of the crime there were
significant questions about payouts that
he made and and you know even beyond
allegations about other children just
the way that he chose to raise his own
children and so when we talk about
michael jackson being transgressive i
think there are a lot of complicated
layers to it
I don't think anyone can deny he was a
complete genius he was someone who took
soul music and morphed it into you know
what we consider modern pop and he is
someone who you can see entire cascades
of people from Michael Jackson taking a
torch from the godfathers of soul and
actually one of my favorite video clips
is of him with James Brown The Godfather
of Soul but Michael Jackson taking that
torch and passing it down to people like
Usher and even another highly troubled
person Chris Brown but Michael Jackson
put his own stamp on everything no one
will ever view dance the same way dance
in the cup in the context of pop culture
because he was able to move and levitate
and really transform air he was able to
make steps out of air he was able to
moonwalk he was able to put himself in a
position where you almost believed that
gravity didn't exist and that is an
incredibly powerful thing to for one man
to do and he's influenced people you
know across the country across the world
at the same time his music and the
collaborators that he's chosen to be
with have also had a profound effect I
mean people like Quincy Jones Richard
Price they contributed to his music but
also to those videos and I think the
legacy of his videos is fascinating
because when you look for example at the
video for bad it was this video with
credits you know it wasn't just the
dance sequence which is what got played
over and over again it also was a video
with a message that starts out with
Michael Jackson as a kid at a prep
school taking you know the train way
past the neighborhoods where his white
colleagues live and going back to a
neighborhood where being bad is being
good and it's a whole morality tale and
it's written by the man who wrote
clockers and it's written with you know
it may seem a little cheesy and outdated
now but it also was the cinematography
is unbelievable and the vision is
unbelievable and the series of videos
that he did real
shows a profound understanding of race
and class dynamics as well as the
transcendent nature of pop culture so
despite his life being incredibly
complicated to the point of seeming
tragic he will be missed